wir wollen aber noch einmal schauen
jetzt nach amerika zwar zu den schwaiger
beziehungsweise ich glaube momentan
sogar in deutschland aber als us
staatsbürgerin natürlich mit einem
trotzdem sehr gespannt einblick in die
richtung und verschweiger wir haben
schon am anfang der ersten wahl nach
miteinander gesprochen jetzt hat sich
das ganze ganz schön lange gezogen es
gab viel hin und her
wie geht es ihnen momentan mit der
ganzen politischen situation in den usa
ja also wir sind natürlich ist alles
sehr entspannt und wir hoffen natürlich
vermeiden da dass er auf mit global
organisationen arbeitet zusammen und
nicht ist es nicht so eine werke first
einzelgänger die meisten merken aber
sagen jetzt wie wir es sehen die meisten
werden verstehen dass merkel muss auf
ein global plattform arbeiten und nicht
dass ein so gegen gegner funktionieren
wenn wir weiterkommen wollen auf dinge
so wie in bayern als world trade
organisation und soweit er zwei themen
die wir hier schon sehr viel besprochen
haben weil sie gerade geführt dass das
größte thema natürlich auch in den
wahlkampf ziehen zum zum einen die
tweets von donald trump und vor allem
die unterstellung bzw
sein glaube dass die wahl nicht sauber
läuft dass es wahlbetrug gibt und damit
zusammen hängt auch die bilderdienste
uns immer mehr orten erreichen wo die
menschen auf die straße gehen um ihren
präsidenten zu verteidigen diese meinung
zu unterstützen wie viel angst macht den
dass das da so wenig vertrauen in die
eigene demokratie ist also ich glaube
nicht dass er wegen wenige vertrauen in
unsere demokratie ist ich glaube das ist
eine kleine sammlung von menschen die
von der präsident angesprochen sind
nämlich seiner anhänger die glauben und
seine worte und seine gesamtbild ist es
also wenn ich sagen relativ würde ich
das nicht bezeichnen als so dass jeder
merkt
sie zu hause denkt das ist alles fake
oder so was unsere demokratie und
unseres system zeigt sich in der tat
dass es funktioniert was und wo wir
probleme haben ist wurde die passion und
das kann man eindeutig sehen wenn man
ein bisschen tiefer gelegt und ich
glaube das ist eher so eine richtige
thema unserer war wirklich ein treuer
wahr ist oder nicht
aber wenn sie sagen die meisten
amerikaner glauben noch an die
demokratie ist ja fast noch schlimmer
dass in diesem stuhl also hier im oval
office im echten in washington jemand
sitzt der anscheinend nicht an sein
eigenes dante die eigene demokratie weil
fast jeder tweet den donald trump jetzt
in letzter zeit abgesetzt da geht es
darum es soll aufgehört werden die
stimmen zu zählen das ist alles betrug
das soll geklaut werden also er
zumindest scheint daran zu glauben dass
die demokratie eben nicht funktioniert
und ausgerechnet er sollte ja absolut
daran glauben dass sein land das
hinbekommt aber man glaubte auf also
wenn man damals schon verfolgt hatte die
letzte kilian denn wissen wir auch oder
die meisten sind ziemlich gut
informieren dass er über 20.000
statements ausgegeben hat oder
missliebige statements also das heißt
und entspricht das sehr viel von was aus
seinem mund kommt ist einfach nicht die
wahrheit
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren